[Música]
y precisamente continuamos hablando de
las inundaciones en Pakistán allí los
muertos ya han ascendido a más de 1.300
y además hay 33 millones de personas
afectadas según el más reciente reporte
de la agencia Nacional de gestión de
desastres del país todo esto debido a
las fuerzas lluvias monzónicas que no
cesan desde junio y también al
derretimiento de los glaciares mientras
que la ONU culpa a la crisis climática
de estos extremos la situación es tan
grave que el gobierno pakistaní afirmó
que un tercio del país está bajo el agua
y por ejemplo en la provincia sureña
decir que ha sido la más afectada existe
el riesgo de que se desborde el lago
manchar que es el más grande de Agua
Dulce en Pakistán y para conversar más
sobre la situación que enfrenta la
nación del sudeste asiático nos acompaña
Rosa Otero ella es portavoz de acnur
España rosa es un placer estar con usted
hoy aquí en directo América empecemos
con un dato Y es que el Primer Ministro
de Pakistán chewa sharif afirmó que hay
partes de su país que parecen como un
mar y esto lo dijo de manera textual en
términos humanitarios Cuáles son las
consecuencias de esto
pues tenemos a centenares de miles de
personas que han tenido que huir de sus
hogares que los han perdido o sea hemos
visto casas que han desaparecido más de
1.300 personas que ya se han
contabilizado que han perdido la vida
terrenos terrenos de cultivo que también
han resultado totalmente dañados porque
están sumergidos por las aguas cabezas
de ganado que también han perecido es
decir tenemos ahora mismo una tragedia
en el corto plazo porque las personas lo
han perdido todo hay muchas personas
heridas tenemos que llegar a muchas
zonas del país que todavía están
bastante aisladas puesto que también las
infraestructuras han resultado dañadas
por por esas lluvias y esas inundaciones
pero también si pensamos en el medio y
largo plazo también hay que pensar en
esa reconstrucción y para que están ya
está pidiendo ayuda para ello desde la
desde la organización de Naciones Unidas
todas las agencias de Naciones Unidas
hemos lanzado un llamamiento por valor
de 160 millones de dólares para apoyar
los esfuerzos del gobierno de Pakistán
que está liderando para ofrecer esa
asistencia pero es necesario poner manos
a la obra y seguir aumentando la ayuda
de hecho por parte de acnur ya hemos
establecido tanto puentes aéreos para
poder llevar ayuda desde desde los
almacenes regionales de Dubai a acaracia
Pakistán para distribuirlo en las
provincias más afectadas también hemos
movilizado con boyes por tierra desde
Uzbekistán y hemos utilizado ya todos
los materiales con los que contábamos en
el país y que teníamos preparados para
la para las operaciones de refugiados a
planos y de población
pakistaní que normalmente desarrollamos
pero claro esta situación estás
inundaciones son las peores en
muchísimos años de hecho yo diría que
solo son comparables pues salas de 2010
que en aquel año perdieron la vida
2010-2000 personas perdón y justo más
adelante Le voy a preguntar sobre eso
Pero antes quiero profundizar un dato
que usted da y es la ONU hizo un llamado
a recolectar 160 millones Para apoyar la
reconstrucción y este llamado lo hizo la
ONU desde hace un par de semanas Cómo va
esta colecta Y si sabe más o menos
cuánto dinero actualmente
de momento la verdad que los donantes se
han respondido de manera muy positiva
pero todavía falta una gran parte de ese
llamamiento por cubrir para poder seguir
llevando asistencia nosotros seguimos
trabajando pero hace falta mucha más
solidaridad para para poder
alcanzar las necesidades de una tragedia
de esta magnitud como decíais las
personas que habéis estado mostrando lo
han perdido absolutamente todo estamos
llevando Pues ahora mismo desde acnur
tiendas de campaña para poder cobijar a
la gente que ahora mismo está viviendo
no solo en campamentos sino también en
el borde de la carretera donde han
podido encontrar un lugar un poco
elevado para para no ser arrastrado por
las crecidas nos están viviendo sin
absolutamente nada envidiar también
lonas plásticas para que puedan
resguardarse enviar alimentos utensilios
de cocina una estufa para que puedan
resguardarse el frío que pronto empezará
con el invierno y también por ejemplo
estufas para cocinar porque en estas sus
hogares los han perdido en el resultado
pues Hay muchísimas casas dañadas no
solo dañadas sino totalmente arrasadas y
no solo las casas sino también los
cultivos como usted lo mencionaba en su
primera pregunta y Es que además de
perderlos por estas inundaciones
Pakistán viene de su peor ola de calor
en la historia que fue precisamente
entre abril y mayo y luego llegan las
lluvias monzónicas al punto que ya le
han pedido a India sobre todo los
organismos internacionales como la ONU
que levanten las sanciones y las
restricciones de exportar alimentos a
Pakistán Cuál es la situación
alimentaria en este momento en Pakistán
Pues en este momento estamos viendo que
los riesgos son muy muy graves porque se
han perdido los medios de vida porque la
gente no puede acceder a sus cultivos
porque han sido totalmente arrasados por
las por las inundaciones han perdido han
tenido que ir con lo puesto nos contaban
algunas personas en Pakistán que habían
tenido 10 minutos en medio de la noche
cuando habían visto que empezaba a subir
el agua para a su familia y ir
corriendo a un sitio elevado dejando
atrás a todo lo que tenían pues no solo
a los cultivos sino también a los
animales que eran su forma de vida con
lo cual hace falta pensar eso también en
el medio plazo no solo llevar ahora la
comida de emergencia sino pensar en cómo
va a ser esa reconstrucción y poderles
proporcionar medios de vida para que
para que puedan seguir adelante y no
veamos situaciones pues como lo que
estamos anunciando también en somalias
hambruna o en todo el cuerno de África
hace falta trabajar desde ya pensando en
la emergencia y en los momentos
posteriores de reconstrucción y ahora sí
hagamos esa comparación histórica porque
la ministra de cambio climático Cherry
revan de Pakistán había dicho que estas
eran las peores inundaciones que visto
en la historia del país y que incluso
superaban los estragos de las
inundaciones de 2010 Qué pasó en ese año
y que está pasando en este momento que
es tan distinto es muy complicado
comparar había hecho la comparación pues
más en número de Muertos
desgraciadamente no una tragedia como
como ver como Cuántas personas habían
parecido En aquel momento en 2010
fallecieron las dos unas 2000 personas
pero todavía no sabemos exactamente Cuál
va a ser la magnitud final de la
tragedia actual o sea llevamos 1300
muertos Apenas ayer eran 1.200 hoy
llevamos 1300 con lo cual Todavía queda
mucho por conocer hay zonas que todavía
pues es complicado acceder y evaluar no
todos los daños y daños humanos y daños
también materiales pero sin dudas son de
las peores que hemos visto en muchos
años y mencionaba yo en la introducción
de esta entrevista que hay una
posibilidad de que se desborde el lago
manchar en zinc yo le quiero preguntar
qué está pasando allí Cuáles serían las
consecuencias y sobre todo que está
pasando con los diques de
Pues estamos movilizando personal
también para poder trabajar por
adelantado en la provincia de sintra
adelantarnos también a posibles nuevos
desplazamientos lo que si se cumplen
estas expectativas y se desborda también
este lago Esto va a forzar a que más
población se desplace a que ciento a que
miles de personas tengan que huir y que
tengan que buscar un campamento donde
donde buscar cobijo o tengan que ser
acogidos por por las poblaciones locales
que como decíais ya de por sí pues
experimentan graves dificultades para
para poder cubrir sus necesidades
básicas Aunque están De todas formas
acogiendo tanto a desplazados como a los
refugiados afganos que además estaban
también en Pakistán y que nuevamente
también se ven afectados por una nueva
catástrofe no solo en esta provincia en
sí sino que además estamos viendo que
también las inundaciones están afectando
a Afganistán o sea es un es una
situación en la que además se prevén
nuevas lluvias para el mes que viene
y tenemos que seguir adelantándonos a
las adelantando materiales y
adelantándonos a las posibles
circunstancias que vengan porque porque
esto no desgraciadamente no no para aquí